what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy developments in
the final attack on titan season
aaron is out of prison people died and
we got a shocking appearance
on parodies island so make sure to stay
tuned for this one if you do enjoy these
attack on titan videos and want to keep
them coming then the best thing you
could do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on time videos
and while you wait for the next insane
episode to drop feel free to check out
our growing attack on time playlist
where we got videos on all the titan
shifters and their powers
all the ackermans and their powers the
titans ranked for weakest the strongest
and much more link to that
is in the description you can also check
out our anime version podcast where we
discuss
anime with people who haven't seen them
before and we are currently talking
about attack on titan so check it out
you can relive this amazing series with
us
link to that is also in the description
now without further ado
let's jump into it this one starts with
armin talking to annie and her crystal
as usual i am of the opinion that armin
likes annie and they'll probably end up
together although armin may have had
feelings already for annie i think the
fact that he ate bertolt means that
those feelings were intensified
since memories and sometimes personality
traits of past
users can enter into current ones and
it's funny to see how hitch has picked
up on armin's feelings too
he went to touch the crystal and hitch
called him out for it
like he's some pervert trying to take
advantage of annie his reaction to this
accusation is absolutely hilarious
showing that he definitely has feelings
for sleeping titan beauty over here
he commented about memories becoming
accessible through touch
which has happened in the past but he's
not too convincing and he
even begs hitch not to tell anyone so he
can continue to come and visit annie
hitch of course was just messing with
him and she wants him to come
saying that annie would be bored with
just her there we don't really know how
much consciousness
annie has in that crystal but if she
does have consciousness
that armin and hitch are doing a huge
favor by coming by and talking because
that would be
very boring otherwise either way love
this scene and i totally ship these two
together let me know your thoughts below
by commenting
ship or skip look forward to figuring
out who wins and it's interesting to see
the newspaper headlines
like the military clings to power by
wrongly imprisoning aaron
again i love that the story shows the
complexities of politics and how
infighting can take place even among
people who supposedly
started on the same side in theory they
should all have what's best for parodies
in mind
and yet the military the scouts aaron
mikasa and armin
all have different positions and views
on what's going on
and i personally think that the military
is handling this horribly
but i guess that's realistic too we get
a bit of yelena
and i'd love to know what you think of
her as a character
do you fundamentally like her or not she
is no doubt pretty crazy and views the
jaeger brothers as
gods and you can tell from her
expressions she gets very emotional
about them
but so far her actions have made more
sense than the military's actions
according to her she just wanted to meet
aaron
and for him to know who she is yelena
says that aaron's actions went beyond
her expectations and she loved the
divine retribution
he brought to marley again she's always
talking about the jaeger bros
in a god-like light but this isn't the
first time we've seen something like
this since
rod rice also said that the founding
titan was god
and when you put aaron and zeke together
you unlock the founding titan's full
powers
so her views aren't that unprecedented
she viewed herself
as powerless before against the mighty
nation of marley
so when aaron proved that people can
fight back against them
of course she glorifies him as she says
history is about to change before our
eyes and she wants to be on the side of
the jaeger brothers
and watch from there she's a very
interesting character and is
machiavellian
af not caring about deceiving the
islanders if
it's for the sake of aldia and zeke's
vision and as onyankopon
later says she's ready to bury anyone
who shows doubt hanji and onyankopon
talk too but these two are definitely
not as extreme as the military and
yellana
as onyankopon said they pushed on for
the sake of their homelands but he
doesn't have that insane look in his
eyes that yelena sometimes gets
we then jump to mikasan armand talking
to the military leader zachary
this is arguably one of the most
interesting scenes in the whole
episode and shows just how split the
military is within itself
although the scouts are technically part
of the military this conversation
reveals that they don't have much say
and are being kept in the dark about
what's happening mikasa and armin want
to see aaron but zachary won't allow it
he says they're done talking suggesting
that they have already decided to kill
aaron and pass on his powers to someone
else
of course because an armin are
completely against this but in
zachary's view aaron is being
manipulated by zeke and they can't have
that happening
again i'm not saying we should trust
zeke but it seems like people are
running on the assumption that he
is 100 going to screw them over and
beyond that they have no
trust in aaron and that he knows what
he's doing
zachary is supposed to be smart he's the
highest ranking official in all but no
he's acting against the people and
against the survey corps
keeping everyone in the dark and let's
not even get into the fact that he seems
to be more interested in torturing
people
in his special torture chair than
helping the people of eldia
when they leave mikasa wants the
eavesdrop on
zachary she doesn't finish her sentence
but it's implied
that she will make sure aaron lives or
is safe before she can finish this
thought an explosion happens killing
zachary and two of his men
and where was the bomb in his torture
chair of all things this is poetic
justice where the tool he used to
torture others
ends up being the same thing that kills
him looking back
you can't really be surprised that this
happened to zachary
since when he wasn't torturing people he
was pretty much making all the decisions
and completely ignoring what the vast
majority wanted
how long could a system like that hope
to continue however the craziest thing
about this in addition to the power
vacuum
which will ensue is that mikasai and
armin were almost caught in the
explosion
they were almost killed it is suggested
that survey core recruits
left a chair there so some jaegerists
caused this
in other words people acting in the name
of aaron caused this and the explosion
almost killed armin and mikasa
arguably two of the biggest motivations
for aaron's war
in my view aaron wants to protect the
people of the island and those close to
him
and that's why he's acting the way he's
acting and if he was crushed when sasha
was killed by gabby which he clearly was
we can only imagine how he would have
felt if people acting in his name killed
mikasa and armin
luckily it didn't happen but it was
close and it goes to show how crazy and
unorganized
this situation is everyone seems to be
acting on their own
and that means anything can happen
people outside don't mourn their
military leader
rather they welcome the explosion and
death proclaiming that
now is the time for them to give their
hearts they know
aaron is fighting for them and giving
them a hope of a safe future the
military's problem was they outlined no
hope and simply imprisoned the only ldn
hero
while being extremely sketchy and acting
behind the scenes
could they really expect a different
result we then find out that aaron
escaped while mikasa wonders what is
happening there are jaeger's
allies hiding in the military and armin
hopes that aaron will understand them
when they talk to him but he's clearly
not so sure anymore in a way it
surprises me that armin and mikasa are
surprised that aaron broke out since he
clearly disagrees with the military's
approach so why would he follow their
orders
however it makes sense that they are
surprised at almost being caught in the
explosion
because the aaron we know would never
want that to happen
the scene where the jaegerists meet up
with aaron is iconic
even in the manga it looked really cool
the way he puts on his coat
and he takes control is epic he tells
them to find where zeke is being kept
he's not playing by the military's rules
anymore
now he's no longer just acting without
them but openly acting against them
ready to take advantage of the power
vacuum caused by zachary's death
pixis is the one who refers to them as
the jaegerists
in this episode and explains that their
goal is to bring zeke and aaron together
he's much more open-minded to
negotiation than zachary was
pixis is definitely the smarter and less
messed up leader so we'll see how he
does
moving forward intelligently he decides
not to go on a witch hunt for jaegers
inside the military and he acknowledges
the military's wrongdoing
saying that their decisions made
soldiers turn their backs on them he
even suggests the idea of surrendering
to aaron but we'll see how all that
actually plays out
definitely the military is in better
hands now than they were with zachary
they know that the rumbling test run
will determine ldn's survival and that
now they have no choice but to look
beyond the murder of zachary
something not easy for them to do but
necessary
pixis will focus on zeke and historia
and on being in a position to negotiate
with the jaegers
hopefully they'll be able to have a less
antagonistic relationship moving forward
another interesting part in this episode
is the conversation with kiyomi and
mikasa
she wants mikasa to escape with her if
things go south
but obviously we know that mikasa would
never do that she even says she's an
eldian rather than an
azumabito or a person from hizuru her
goal is for the place where she was born
to have a future
very interesting and i think that is
aaron's goal too so i wish mikas and
aaron were closer right now but to be
fair
it's not mikasa's fault as much as it is
errands aaron is to blame because he's
keeping a distance from her
and the others kyomi lets her know that
the azumabito legacy is contingent on
the rumbling working
otherwise the royal family will be hung
out to dry another interesting political
development showing how modernization
and the struggle for survival has led
the hizru nation
to not care that much about its royal
family who have become known for being
wretched money-grubbing vixens
interestingly enough even though mikasa
knows that kiyomi
is interested in the resources like we
do kiyomi says that the family hasn't
lost their pride
and she wants mikasa to be safe no
matter what happens to the nation
kiyomi is also turning out to be a more
complicated character than she
at first appeared but yeah now we know
that her position as an influential
hizuru leader
is very much subject to change depending
on how things go
eventually connie seemingly turns on
mikasa asking her which side she's on
as if you have to be completely on one
or the other
mikasa mentions that she almost got
caught in the explosion so it's
surprising he even has to ask
implying that she's on the side of the
military or scouts however this is
too simplistic she may not care about
the jaegerists but she definitely cares
about aaron
so it will be interesting to see how
this develops but as i've been
mentioning mikasa has matured and she's
clearly not someone who will support
aaron over everyone else 100
anymore in many ways this series has
been a story of mikasa and
aaron growing apart and we don't know
what will happen but i really hope they
can make peace at some point
they're another couple that i would ship
so hard really hoping for a happy ending
for these two although i know that it's
probably not super likely
more crazy things are being set up we
see falco and gabby enter the marlene
restaurant
and peek is even there on paradise
island just like aaron was in marley
so the marlene attack and final fight is
imminent at this point
so many conflicting sides and factions
all wanting their different things and
with the explosion all-out war is pretty
much
in motion in the preview we learned the
next episode is called children of the
forest we're asked if a rewarding future
lies beyond the truth or something else
i absolutely love these questions at the
end of episodes
they're always so deep there's this
constant search for freedom and truth
and attack on titan but there's also the
very real possibility that perhaps it's
better to live in blissful ignorance
sometimes
like how the king of the walls built a
paradise and erased people's memories so
they could enjoy their remaining years
in peace
like aaron i greatly value freedom but
in attack on titan nothing is black and
white
and with every choice you make there are
undeniably pros and cons
either for you and or for others we also
see levi
and zeke and since the episode is called
children of the forest and they're in a
forest we can bet there will be a big
focus on them in the next one
will we see them team up or a rematch
only time will tell
but whatever happens it will be crazy we
know that especially those of us who
have read the manga
and that is it for this one as always
let me know how you like this episode
and what you expect to see happening
next below i love how it seems like the
studio is taking their time with the
story and it doesn't feel rushed to me
you gotta do an epic story like attack
on titan justice and i think they've
been doing a great job this season
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos they want to keep them
coming then the best thing you can do is
warhammer smash that like button until
it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next insane episode to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
all the ackermans and their powers the
titan drink for weakest the strongest
and much more
link to that is in the description you
can also check out our anime version
podcast where we discuss
anime with people who haven't seen them
before and we are currently talking
about
attack on titan so check it out you can
relive this amazing series with us
link to that is also in the description
and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grotto the world acquire respect but
they have a liam thompson
al-jatal dr cortman johnny boyd draws
emperor otaku
spidey life tinel baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis and are pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kozlowski
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
fond
rethuen de aura alicia actor bonnie
parks hinokami and water
the red haired raven joanne garcia jack
watches anime fat boy games ted note
head deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life waifus and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link to that is in the
description
if you're interested you could also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button
that you've hopefully already clicked so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you